[تصفيق]
المجد لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
السيده الرئيسه
السيدات والساده النواب والبرلمانيون شكرا
على هذه الكلمات القويه
شكرا
لكم على عنايتكم الشخصيه
لاوكرانيا
شكرا على
مقاربتكم المليئه والمفعمه بالطاقه شكرا
على كل جهودكم شكرا على
الدعم الاوروبي خلال كل هذه الفتره
هذه الطريق الوحيده بالنسبه لنا من اجل
التوجه نحو الامام ان اوروبا محظوظه
بهذا البرلمان الاكبر في العالم
هذا البرلمان
الذي نجد فيه اغلبيه عظمى تساند المبادئ
التي ندعمها
السيدات والساده
ممثلون قد البلدان الاوروبيه الساده
القاده الاوروبيون ايها المواطنون
والمواطنات في اوروبا
انتم تمثلون
ممثلي اوروبا انتم قاده اوروبا
السلام
وهذا افضل ما تقدمه اوروبا للعالم طريقه
في الحياه على النمط الاوروبي
مقاييس اوروبيه
طريقه في الحياه والعيش الاوروبيه حيث
حقوق الفرد هي التي تسود
والدول
والمجتمعات تتعارض وتتضامن ضمن
تنوعي القيم
قيم الاشخاص المختلفه تتعاضد فيما بينها
بينها ولا يتم انتهاك الحدود فيها
ولا تشعرون بانكم تخترقون الحدود حيث
الناس يثقون بالمستقبل
ويستعدون
بالنزول الى شوارع للدفاع عن مستقبلهم
العقبه الوحيده امامكم هي
الانتخابات الانتخابات هي الفاصل وهي
الحاسم هذه الديمقراطيه هذه هي طريقه
الحياه في اوروبا بالنسبه لنا في اوكرانيا
هذه هي دارنا
هذا هو الطريق الذي نريد ان ندافع عنه من
اجل الوصول الى دارنا هذه
انا اقف امامكم اليوم من اجل الدفاع عن
هذه الطريق وهذا الباب للدخول الى هذه
الدار كل الاوروبيين بغض النظر عن
سننهم
وعقائدهم
وطبقاتهم الاجتماعيه كلهم يدافعون عن هذه
الاراده لدينا تواريخ مختلفه ولكن كلنا
لدينا تاريخ مشترك والتاريخ الاوروبي نحن
اوروبيون ان طريقه العيش الاوكرانيه
والاوروبيه
تتحددهما الخطر
بسبب حرب تتلتي لتاريه شموليه لانه اذا
سقطت اوكرانيا فاننا نمط حياتكم سينهار
وسيسقط نمط حياه البلدان 27 للاتحاد
الاوروبي نمط حياتكم سيتلاشى لا ينبغي
علينا ان نسمح بحدوث في ذلك هذه الحرب
الشموليه التي تم من قبل روسيا ليست فقط
حرب عاديه
للاستحواذ على اراضي في جزء بعيد من
اوروبا التهديد الحقيقي يتمثل هنا بان نرى
طاغيه حقيقيه
يمتلك احتياطات ضخمه من الاتحاد السوفيتي
يحصل على اسلحتين منظمه شموليه كايران من
اجل استمرار في هذه الحرب
ومن اجل
الغاء كل القيم الضروريه في اوروبا الا
وهي احترام
حياه البشر بالنسبه حياته البشر غير مهمه
وقيمتهم الوحيده تتمثل بمحافظهم الماليه
الالاف والملايين من الروسهم فقط يعتبرون
ذخائر للمدافع
وذخائر بشريه في ساحات المعركه
الجنود
يخضعون وياتمرون
هذه فقط هذه القيم التي يريد ان ينشرها
قاده الروس
ان العداله الاجتماعيه والتنوع
خنعتان وهم يحاولون الاستثمار في انعدام
البشريه لكي تصبح حلا بشريه هي القاعده في
القرن الحادي والعشرين نحن لا نريد ذلك
نحن في اوروبا نريد الدفاع عن شيء اخر
نريد الدفاع
عن اوروبا ضد القوى المناهضه لاوروبا في
جميع انحاء العالم معكم في ساحات المعارك
[تصفيق]
اياك
واريد ان اشكركم ايضا
على مساعدتكم للدفاع عن انفسنا والدفاع
عنكم فاننا اذ ندافع عن انفسنا ندافع عنكم
هذا مهم لمجتمعاتكم بغض النظر عن اممكم
وجنسياتكم نحن نريد ان نكافح عدم احترام
عدم مبادئ عدم الاحترام نحن نريد ان
نعول على النزاهه
من اجل مستقبل اطفالنا واحفادنا
الشرط الاساسي لذلك يتمثل بالامن والسلم
[تصفيق]
هذا الامر الممكن
لن يتحقق الا اذا
قمنا بحمات هذه
البلاد الاوروبيه
انتصارنا فقط من شانه ان يضمن لكم ذلك كل
حقوق اوروبيه حصلتم عليها يجب المحافظه
عليها وحمايتها
السيد والساده القاده الاوروبيون
البرلمانيون الاوروبيون الموظفون
الاوروبيون الصحفيون الحاضرون هنا
طاقم المرافقه والامن العسكريون والشرطيون
والمنقذون والدبلوماسيون
والاساتذه والعلماء الاطباء
السائقون
العاملون المزارعون والفلاحون
العاملون في المصانع ارباب الاعمال
الاجراء
العاملون في المصارف في مجال الطاقه في
الشبكات الطاقه
النقابيون المواطنون ممثلي المنظمات غير
الحكوميه المنتجون الممثلون القانونيون
المدافعون عن حقوق الانسان ان مصيره
اوروبا
لم يكن ابدا يعول على سياسه كما هو
الان لكل دوره على كل واحد منكم قادر ان
يكون له تاثيره المباشر من اجل الحصول على
نتيجه ملموسه وعلى انتصار مشترك
[تصفيق]
انتم تصفقون لي انتم
لا ينبغي ان تصفقوا لي ينبغي لكم ان
تصفقوا كل
[موسيقى]
المئات والالاف من الاشخاص الذين دعموا
اوكرانيا في هذه المعركه التاريخيه شكرا
شكرا
[تصفيق]
اريد ان اشكركم اشكركم
كل اولئك النساء والرجال الذين ساعدوا
شعبنا
المواطنون مواطنين الذين
قمتم باستقبالهم هنا نحن نريد المزيد من
مساعدتكم من اجل تامين الماوى واللجوء
لمواطنين والنازحين ودعم اولئك الذين
يكافحون
الاعتداء الروسي واولئك الذين يناضلون من
اجل مقاومه الاعتداء الاوروبي انها مساله
حياه ووجود بالنسبه لاوروبا
اريد ايضا ان اشكرا جميع الذين ساعدوا
اوروبا من خلال اوكرانيا من اجل تقديم
الاسلحه والطاقه الطاقه والكهرباء
والمعدات كل هذه المعدات التي ما كان
بامكاننا الحصول عليها خلال هذه الحرب
اريد ان اشكركم من صميم قلبي ان اشكركم
ايها البرلمانيون انت روبرتا من خلال
اتخادكم هذا القرار بالدفاعي على طريقه
عيشنا بهذا العناد والاصرار من اجل الدفاع
عن طريقه العيش الاوروبيه
[تصفيق]
لقد اثبتم من خلال قراراتكم الشجاعه من
خلال قوتكم
لقد اثبتم بانكم تستطيعون ان تكونون دار
العداله والحريه
اتذكر الايام الاولى من الغزو حيث
حيث روسيا كانت تهدد
بكسر اواصر في اوروبا وانا على يقين بان
الاعتداء الروسي
ينكسر ضد دفاعاتنا في اليوم السادس من
الاعتداء انتم اعتمدتم قرارا بالكلمات فقط
لنضالنا ومن اجل قبول اوكرانيا كعضو مرشح
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا قرار حمسنا
واعطانا الحماسه للدفاع والقتال
شكرا لكم على ذلك اليوم
المجلس الاوروبي سيلتئم
وستكون فرصه لي ان اشكر رؤساء دول
والحكومات على قراراتهم الشجاعه في هذه
السنه هذه القرارات التي سمحت
لشعبنا وعلى قناتنا
ان يصنعوا ما كان يعتبر مستحيلا اي ان
تتخلصوا من تلك التبعيه المكلفه
تبعيه اوروبا للطاقه الروسيه
الروسيه لقد اثبتم بانكم تستطيعون الدفاع
عن انفسكم واثبتم بانكم تستطيعون ان تدافع
عنفسكم ضد
اختراقات الاستخبارات الروسيه في الاراضي
الاوروبيه من
الاستهداف معرضيها للمره الاولى ساعد
الاتحاد الاوروبي بلد من البلدان بهذا
الحجم وهذه المره الاولى ايضا التي نرى
فيها هذه الايرادات في الاصلاح من اجل
التحديث من اجل الاصلاح من اجل اصلاح
المؤسسات ايضا نحن ايضا نريد ان نصبح عضوا
في الاتحاد الاوروبي اوكرانيا تودوا
المشاركه في هذه الجهود اوكرانيا تريد ان
تكسب انضمامها في اوروبا منتصره
ايها الاصدقاء الاعزاء
البعض منكم
ربما لم يشعروا مسبقا
بقوه كلمه نمط العيش والحياه
ولكن كل البلدان وكل اوكرانيون قاموا بجمع
وتعضيض كل الجهود لماذا لاننا اقتربنا من
بعضنا البعض وفق مبادئ قويه على مستوى على
اساس المساواه وعلى عدم المساسب باوروبا
نحن نعرف بان كل القاده الاوروبيين
يريدون الدفاع عن هذه الفكره
نحن لا نريد ان نستسلم لا نريد ان نفقد
الوقت لا نريد
الهزيمه لا نريد ان نخسر المكتسبات
الاوروبيه نريد ان تبقى اوروبا اوروبا
وهذا الامر سيكون ممكنا طالما كنا متوحدين
كلما قمنا بتغذيه هذه الطريقه في الحياه
اعيد واكرر شكرا لكم
وادعو الجميع ادعوكم جميعا الى اوكرانيا
المجد لاوكرانيا والمجد للاوكرانيين
شكرا جزيلا